eu sou inglês pereira 17 anos e na minha
jornada até agora eu já vivi muitas
peripécias entre elas
acabei desenvolvendo projetos de ensino
e extensão e pesquisa
saca só eu e um monte de adolescente da
minha idade querido revolucionar o mundo
com idéias criativas
eu trouxe um exemplo de um projeto e zac
foi de hoje sujas bons idéias
eu e mais três garotas sentamos e
pensamos por que não levar para as
outras pessoas
o maior poder que elas têm o poder de
pensar ea gente cria uma sala de imersão
utilizando a mesma tecnologia do homem
que é um cérebro humano
outro projeto muito legal eu participei
foi fichado ora esses aí foi que a gente
foi lá sim sabe eu vejo a região que é
muito quente
achei muita dificuldade com água daí eu
me juntei com mais duas pessoas o rácio
a érika ea gente tem uma tecnologia que
aumenta a rentabilidade da água no solo
semiárido os agentes simplesmente olhou
pra nossa realidade disse
e será que a gente não pode fazer nada
esses projetos me ensinaram na prática
quem depende da minha idade eu posso
revolucionar muitas e muitas realidades
nem parece tão fácil falar assim na eu
fiz isso eu fiz aquilo mas a minha
jornada até agora não foi fundamentada
apenas nesses grandes eventos não e sim
nas minhas experiências diárias por
favor guarda em uma frase
os detalhes formam o indivíduo essa só
eu
aos três anos de idade os meus pais
contam que foi uma das épocas mais
complicadas relacionamento entre pai e
filha
sabe porque foi nessa época que comecei
a ser excluída por crianças da minha
idade é é bem complicado eu comecei a me
sentir um pouco mais retraída eu comecei
a ter medo das relações humanas e até
mesmo começar a brincar sozinha
quer dizer nem tão sozinho assim é por
favor preste atenção na imagem
na imagem vocês estão vendo uma
garotinha de phishings vermelho que sou
eu e ao meu lado tem a expansão da minha
criatividade aos três anos de idade eu
fiz uma simbologia daquilo que sentiu
mais falta quer um amigo e daí eu queria
um amigo imaginário
chamado hips sim os meus pais tiveram
medo sim os meus pais pensaram meu deus
a minha filha nunca vai ter uma infância
normal
sim eles tiveram muito muito medo mas
apesar de tudo isso eles resolveram ter
empatia pelo meu processo e respeitar o
meu tempo de desenvolvimento e de
descobrimento é o show me quiser que os
meus pais me permitiram c e nenhum
momento eu sofri inibição só por ser
criança
já passavam com tanto medo eles
decidiram de fazenda mais presente na
minha jornada o ribs mais tarde ele se
tornou a minha principal ferramenta de
como foi competência comunicativa eu tô
conversando com vocês agora isso aqui
foi construído pela permissão que os
pais eram a uma criança que cria um
amigo imaginário
eu fui passando por vários documentos
entre eles
teve uma época que foi bem complicada
admito foi quando meu pai teve um caso
seres imo de depressão e de 8 anos de
idade
eu não sabia o que era depressão eu não
sabia nem o que era suicídio mas a minha
casa estava muito estranha sabe e se
vocês me perguntarem agora um mini
hábito que eu não abro mão eu vou dizer
que é o diálogo aberto com os meus pais
só que naquele momento era perceptível
que as coisas mudariam
eu não sabia o que era depressão mas eu
queria fazer alguma coisa porque eu
queria minha família de volta e foi aos
oito anos de idade que eu tomei uma
decisão
eu quero ajudar o meu pai não fecha o
dia as crianças evitem um lugar chamado
igreja lá eu me senti muito acolhida e
muito engraçada não só por palavras e
ações manchete sabe pessoas relações
humanas e eu disse era se eu pegar essa
sensação de me sentir acolhida e levar
para o meu pai vai que ele se sente bem
também e eu cheguei em casa numa
esperança só enche pra caramba não o
saco do meu pai pai eu preciso como
goulart pai o senhor tem que conhecer e
olhadela era tipo uma criança tentando
ensinar alguma coisa eu tô com depressão
minha filha e foi insistindo muito
insistindo insistindo e
depois vai comigo eu sei que naquele
momento ele foi porque eu pedi pra ele
mas três meses depois o meu pai estava
ainda por conta dele
hoje a minha família estruturada
graças a uma criança que foi ouvida aos
oito anos de idade
eu costumo dizer que eu não tenho uma
dívida com os meus pais porque naquele
momento eu não pensei ah eu vou ajudar o
meu pai porque eu preciso que ele fique
bem para trabalhar pra pagar uma escola
eu gosto do meu pai velho porque meu
deus eu quero minha família bem para
conseguir ter uma jornada legal e
tranquila
não eu pensei eu quero ajudar o meu pai
porque ele é o meu pai sabe aquela coisa
de adultos chegarem para a apae chegarem
para seus filhos e falar filho o pai
está cuidando de você pra que no futuro
você faça a mesma coisa comigo vai ser
uma troca equivalente
isso nunca pode se tornar uma dívida não
é uma obrigação retribuir o amor que os
nossos países dão sabe é por amor e
aprendi muito isso aos oito anos de
idade
bem eu fui crescendo e passando por
muitos e muitos desdobramentos é claro
mas ser ouvida e independente da minha
idade ter espaço independente da minha
idade me fez sentir e fé dois momentos
importantes
o primeiro foi que aos 11 anos de idade
eu me dei conta de que o ribs ele não
era só um amigo imaginário e sim a minha
consciência horríveis ele estava aqui do
meu lado
daí decidi trazer ele pra dentro de mim
e aos 11 anos de idade eu percebi o
quanto ele é importante eo quanto ele
fazia parte da minha trajetória
outra segundo o segundo momento foi aos
15 anos de idade
eu me dei conta de que eu não sabia o
que era ser eu
normal né mas eu não farei isso daí é
que esse reconhecimento interno e eu fui
assim quer saber então o que é ser eu
sabe para o ano disse uma construção a
desconstrução haver naturalmente e um
detalhe que marcou essa minha caminhada
de descobrimento foi o despertar bem 8
18 de abril de 2018
eu estava tentando ajudar mas
não conseguia me concentrar e estava
muito frustrada porque também estava com
sono e aquela coisa que vai e vem que
vem que vem você fica meu deus eu tenho
prova e só que não consegui estudar a
idéia desse direito a um pouco quando
tentei eu não conseguia dormir
aí eu pensei relaxa a insônia você vai
passar a noite acordado então é melhor
voltar a estudar
quando eu voltei pra estudar eu não
conseguia me concentrar e eu entendi que
não era o meu corpo que estava cansado
mas era minha mente a minha mente ela
estava sobrecarregada e daí eu parei
disse
para tu vai estar muito estudar por um
monte de coisa tem que fazer muita
natação para prender um assunto porque
não aprende mais sobre você e eu comecei
a me perguntar como é que você se
sentindo e eu peguei um caderno velho
que eu tenho latim é tenho ela na minha
casa e eu comecei a escrever como é que
eu me sentia e daí foi dando páginas na
verdade nesse dias foi 50 minutos de
escrita e pela internet uma folha
inteira escrito sobre mim nessas páginas
tem escrito coisas que eu ignorava
naturalmente coisas que eu tinha vivido
há três semanas atrás e que ainda estão
influenciando o meu estado naquele
momento e eu parei fiquei tipo como
assim
eu não peguei na minha casa a gente tem
um dever funcional é um livro que tem
várias mensagens legais pra você
despertar no seu dia e aí eu peguei e
uma mensagem que eu fiquei muito
assustada com o que tinha feito
e aí eu consegui dormir no outro dia eu
acordei mais cedo eu vou à escola set eu
acordei a 5 pra ficar até seis fazendo
isso e ver como é que eu diria ser desde
isso fui para a escola o médio foi como
qualquer outro dia mas à noite foi
diferente eu não estava esgotada
minha mente não estava sobrecarregada eu
ainda estava em green e eu consegui
dormir naquele dia e assim foi passando
e fazendo esse processo e tal e eu
mostrei o caixão que despertar diário
todos os dias eu tento fazer esse
encontro comigo mesmo uma despertar de
área ele foi super importante porque a
partir da minha autoanálise
eu comecei a respeitar o meu processo e
no meu kit de sobrevivência entrou o meu
silêncio a minha
pausa ea minha meditação só que não
adianta chegar pra você e dizer olha
leva o despertar diário que vai dar tudo
certo
não vai ser uma propaganda falsa cada
pessoa que apresente tem o seu próprio
tipo de despertar é um processo lento
gradual progressivo e totalmente
individual e nem sempre dá certo por
isso que você vai se descobrindo
só que nesse despertar diário é tinha 15
anos e que outras coisas envolveram
envolvência minha jornada 15 anos aquela
pressão para você decidir o que você vai
ser o resto da vida e eu ficava meu deus
do céu tenham que mexam do tempo
bem você sabe me dizer com a previsão do
tempo de hoje
a previsão do tempo do agora é a
previsão existencial o tempo está
passando e é um bem não renovável
naquele momento eu fiquei para eu tenho
meu tempo e tem uma trajetória
mas o que fazer num tempo está passando
é necessário despertar e foi daí onde
surgiu o despertar diário
quando me dei conta do meu próprio tempo
aqui tava vendo um efeito manada que
muitos adolescentes lá fora estão
sofrendo com a pressão social para
decidir o resto da vida e 17 anos por
exemplo
e aqui não vai ter efeito manada estava
no meu deus que quando despertei o
efeito manada passou eu fiz assim e aqui
toda a minha trajetória
quando você desperta você acorda pra si
e acorda pra sua própria rota agora
tinha minha própria rota para seguir mas
o que fazer nossa própria rota as coisas
ficam mais complicadas quando você sai
da zona de conforto
uma coisa que eu percebi que faltava na
fase juvenil e que marcou a despertar na
minha fase juvenil foi a minha abertura
mental quanto ao meu tempo de
descobrimento interpessoal
mas lá fora não tem isso não era muita
falta de empatia da minha parte e viver
isso dentro da minha casa e chegar lá
fora e encontrar meus amigos com as
pessoas da minha idade e não tem nada
disso
olha deixa explicar uma coisa
a fase da adolescência é a ponte entre a
fase infantil ea fé adulta se essa ponte
cá e fica sem caminho e como é que você
quer dar o próximo passo para a fase
adulta se você não vai ter um passo
anterior a um pai quando deve ter o seu
filho e diz que ele é responsável
só porque ele adolescente não espere um
adulto responsável porque é um processo
é um ciclo da vida eu sou adolescente é
um só a luta mas em nenhum momento eu
quero ser chamado de irresponsável por
causa disso porque os meus pais me
confiaram desde cedo uma missão que a
missão de ética moral dos meus valores
do que eu posso desenvolver o que eu
posso fazer
então não me diga que sou responsável e
irresponsável só porque eu sou
adolescente quando eu fui entendendo
isso me veio uma palavra muito legal por
se sentir na prática que a maturidade
mas peraí hoje eu falar sobre isso eu
tenho certeza que há um gay até você que
vai estar assistindo esse tal que agora
eu tenho certeza que quando você vê o
meu tipo maturidade não vem com a idade
você pensou
meu deus do céu quem a pessoa brega que
vai utilizar isso todo mundo sabe que
maturidade não tinha qualidade mas será
mesmo que as pessoas sabem se tão novo
tão vazio afora todo mundo diz que na
atualidade vêm com a idade mas na
maturidade ela não vem com a idade
porque é um processo lento e gradual
progressivo individual assim como
despertar diário é a maturidade é o que
você faz com o tempo está passando
não é com a quantidade de experiências
boas ou experiência sei lá que você usa
depois para contar a história
não vem com a idade nuvem maturidade
atitude é o que você faz duas coisas que
estão ao seu redor
isso foi só aprende entendendo que a
maturidade quando me dei conta da minha
própria maturidade que era respeitar
também o meu processo
eu fui pra outras correntes por exemplo
a questão do ser
a lei mas já fala do sef deixa eu falar
uma coisa
a maternidade ela possui três pilares a
maturidade é construída no indivíduo a
maturidade é construída pelo indivíduo
ea maturidade é conseguir durante toda a
vida do indivíduo então se você
encontrar uma pessoa que levanta a mão
dizendo só maturidade pura eu já vivi
séculos e séculos e eu sei de muita
coisa
desconfiança pessoa porque a maturidade
ela não
acaba mas eu adoro entende o meu tempo
entende entrava na minha própria
trajetória
mas como é que eu ia tomar minhas
decisões as minhas próprias decisões
era mais complicado está numa trajetória
própria sabe e daí fui me dando conta de
algumas palavras chaves como por
exemplos e olha ventar ser você é
não me diga que você a será que sou será
que penso que sou quem será que isso não
você é as coisas ficam bem mais fáceis
quando você confirma isso pra você mesmo
você não precisa esperar nada chegar por
exemplo na minha idade não preciso ir à
faculdade chegar para me tornar alguém
eu já sou alguém agora isso é mais do
que fundamental pra começar a minha
jornada inicia missão e continuar minha
trajetória
outra coisa legal foi a questão de estar
aqui de estar presente
por favor quem está aqui levante a mão
quem só presente levante a mão que massa
só quem está aqui é diferente de estar
presente todo mundo está aqui mas
pouquíssimos estão presentes presença é
posicionamento tá na tua trajetória mais
belas agora tem que andar nela e andar
se posicionar para poder saber qual a
rota qual caminho seguir é bem
complicado
o posicionamento é tipo sol o sol tá lá
e o sistema solar está lá
se eu sair de cena o sistema solar faz
isso aqui ó
quando você se posiciona na sua
trajetória na sua jornada
você consegue visualizar as coisas que
podem acontecer na sua vida não
significa que você vai ter controle de
tudo por favor estamos falando de
realidade mas significa que você vai
está ciente do que está acontecendo e
isso também a maturidade mas não adianta
só está presente na sua jornada
você precisa também é uma coisa que eu
chamo de espírito de ousadia
sacou o experiente zagueiro gum é a
autenticidade
mas não é só isso sabe como ensinou
muito na alta performance por exemplo
não é só isso
você precisa ter se posicionado jornada
mas você precisa utilizar sua essência a
seu favor
também está presente nas demais jornadas
sabe marcar a vida do próximo e 4
jornada é mais ou menos isso então
espírito do dia exige coragem exige
muita coragem e até mais utiliza para me
manter aqui mediante a vocês me está com
a minha essência com que eu tenho para
oferecer por muito tempo
é o pensei sobre isso tudo traz essa
noite são frutos do que costuma estudar
atualmente analisando meu passado porque
enxerga o meu passado não como algo que
passou mas como o que faz a total é
feito em mim sabe esse resultado eu sou
resultado de pessoas
eu sou resultado de humanos eu sou
resultado dos meus pais eu sou resultado
da minha família eu não cheguei aqui à
toa
eu sou formada por detalhes ea minha
construção humana é fundamentada nos
detalhes que eu vivi que eu vivo todos
os dias
[Música]
certa vez eu ouvi de uma pessoa você
está à frente do seu tempo garota e eu
olhei pra pessoa e disse eu não estou à
frente do meu tempo eu me encontro no
meu próprio tempo
obrigada pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]